[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger potion in
1975 he was responsible for ushering in
the era of the summer blockbuster with a
heart-pounding thriller ja then he
brought back the thrill of the Saturday
matinee with 1981's
Raiders of the Lost Ark
[Music]
and the following year his story about a
little lost alien named et became the
highest-grossing movie of all time of
course we're talking about one of
Hollywood's most successful filmmakers
Steven Spielberg the Academy Award
winner has directed 29 motion pictures
from biopics 20 House Democrats to sci
fi adventurer's the sagas of war and at
age 70 he's showing no signs of slowing
down with four more features in
production now HBO is pulling back the
curtain on his 50-year career with a new
documentary titled simply enough
spielberg every time i start a new scene
i'm nervous and it's like going to
school having to take a test
i'd never heard the lines spoken before
I don't know what I'm gonna think of
hearing the lines I don't know I'm gonna
tell the actors I don't know where I'm
gonna put the camera and every single
time it's the same but I'll tell you
it's the greatest feeling in the world
tell you why it's a good feeling the
more I'm feeling confident and secure
about something the less I'm gonna put
out the more I'm feeling oh this could
be a major problem in getting the story
cold I'm gonna work overtime to meet the
challenge and get the job done
joining us now is Susan Lacey the
producer and director of Spielberg she
is best known as the creator and
executive producer of the PBS series
American masters Susan good morning
thanks for joining us thank you I'm
delighted to be and well done how did
you convince Steven Spielberg to do this
you know it wasn't that hard I shouldn't
say that that's something I'd wanted to
do for a long time and then I
interviewed him for a film I did on
David Geffen he and we had a really good
time and enjoyed it and he does not do
interviews but he did that because they
were friends and he and we had a go and
he felt very comfortable and I got sort
of the message that okay maybe I'm ready
for this but only if you do the film Wow
14 interviews with him yeah some 30
hours of film over a long period of time
it was actually shocking to me how much
time he gave I didn't expect it right
and first interview you know two hours
later he was 11 years old and this is
fun what are we doing here together
that's kind of the way it went surprised
both of us right that and we spent a lot
of time together and and he opened up in
wait you know he's never done a
director's commentary yeah he doesn't do
interviews never participated in
anything about him one of the stories I
love is was goes back to you know he was
kind of obsessed with Lawrence of Arabia
as a kid and it actually almost
discouraged him from being a director
right well when he told me that story I
knew that I was gonna open the film with
that mm-hmm for a couple of reasons one
is it's shocking that at a young age he
almost gave up his dream of being a
director why did he almost give it up
because the bar is he said the bar was
so high I didn't think he could ever
achieve that but with that what that
told me the stories it told me is that
that was his aspiration yes where he
wanted to go yeah and then was
interesting you talked to not just
Steven but you talked to all kinds of
Hollywood luminaries including
his peers some would say Martin Scorsese
Francis Ford Coppola how do they think
of him in this particular moment well he
was part of that 70s group of what they
call the movie brats and I have a
wonderful section in there of all this
footage that Steven shot during that
time which nobody except maybe his
archivist has ever seen lock and key
and they were all so young and starting
out and showing each other their stuff
and George Lucas says in the film we
never thought were gonna make any money
at it which always makes me laugh wow we
never thought we were gonna make any
money at this we were just a bunch of
kids you know but they all knew from the
beginning that Steven was not the same
as that right they all thought of him as
kind of a nerd didn't know he's a nerd
and also he had very just different
aspirations yeah he wanted to be David
Lean they wanted to be John Cassavetes
right totally different sensibility
there and Steven knew from the beginning
which is another reason for starting
with Lawrence of Arabia that that was
the direction he wanted to go he wasn't
going to be a scrappy
independent filmmaker it was a Hollywood
of the 29 features he's directed over
the years did he share with you his
favorites well his his answer is I'm a
father to all my children all my movies
and I'm not picking my favorite but and
he actually didn't I think there are
some films that are more
autobiographical than others yeah and I
think Close Encounters was probably the
first really personal film because he
wrote it mm-hmm by the way which is
which we don't think of we don't think
of Close Encounters and and he had made
a little movie when he was 16 coal fire
light which is his first movie about
contact with aliens and you know in that
the aliens weren't such good guys we are
excited to watch it this evening on HBO
Susan Bravo on being the director for
Steven Spielberg daunting the premiere
is again tonight at 8:00 tonight at 8:00
p.m. on HBO thanks Susan
thank you rats